he was all production falling this year
according to the nation's biggest and
fastest growing oil company EOG
resources slashing spending by 40%
reducing drilling by almost half and
will maintain output at 2014 levels this
is from a company that has been growing
their output at 50 percent a year since
2009
Yoji says if they're cutting back so
will the rest of the industry but that
forecasts contradict figures from the US
Energy Information Administration who
say production is going to grow at
almost 8 percent this year so who is
right here on US oil production well
hopefully to settle this is Bloomberg
oil and gas reporter Brad Olsen from
Houston so where do we get these two
divergent forecasts who's right here
I think that'll depend on the shell
companies and which of them follow the
EO G's of the world and which of them
continue to pump and that's the great
unknown question out there in the market
right now
will there be companies like aog that
are going to stop drilling and kind of
put on the brakes or will there be a lot
of companies that keep going and try to
keep pumping and kind of survive by
producing even at minimal margins well I
think that's a great point Brad so a og
is a market leader if they're going to
essentially not I would say cut
production because they're not going to
be increasing it right by the amount
that they have in the past wouldn't
others have to follow suits that's the
big thing one of the things that's
keeping the companies pumping the ones
that are continuing to grow production
is hedges so they've locked in prices at
a little bit higher rates from last year
and that allows them to keep going but
the companies like aog that have not
hedged a lot of their production are
able to stop production and say we're
going to wait for the price to come back
up that's exactly what they're doing
they're saying there's no reason to pump
with prices being this low and to take
margins being this low and so that's
sort of the decision the big question
mark is what's going to happen with all
the rest of the producers right it's
almost 8,000 companies that pump for oil
in the United States and 8,000 companies
don't always work together in march in
lockstep know when they're not all in
the same area either right Brad that's
right there's different kinds
mechanisms and techniques for doing
drilling some of them drill horizontally
and some of them drill vertically and in
many different areas of the United
States and expecting them to all work
together would be like imagining hurting
8,000 cats it's almost impossible and it
doesn't really compare very well to OPEC
which we know is only 12 countries right
so imagine it's difficult for OPEC to
work together imagine how much harder it
is for 8,000 US producers to work
together so Brad where do we really know
this supplier oversupply comes from is
it out of OPEC or is it out of the US
well at the beginning that was out of
the US in the last few years a whole lot
of new production came from the United
States because of the shale revolution
but there also was new production out of
OPEC for a long time there was not
production out of Iraq it took many
years for that to happen and then of
course we know that there was a civil
war in Libya so there was production
that was off line there and those things
came online again as shale continued to
grow and so that's why you have this big
glut that exists right now in the market
right Brad thank you so much Bradley
Olsen from Houston our Bloomberg News
reporter